d'abord donc la suite de notre série d'
enquête sur la vie sexuelle en france
aujourd'hui en quoi at elle évolué ces
dernières années
et bien ce soir nous évoquons les femmes
il y à 25 ans un groupe chantaient les
femmes libérées et c'était presque un
cliché pour les magazines et bien les
temps ont changé l'émancipation des plus
un slogan les comportements masculins et
féminins semble-t-il se rapprochent
notamment pour ces femmes qui sont dans
le deuxième âge de leur vie et qui ne
renonce à rien reportage osé devant la
pierre hervé podio avec des compagnons
qui pourrait être leur fils madonna des
mi-lourds et sharon stone montre le
chemin des cougars des felynes qui a 40
50 ans et plus chasse et ne capturent
que des petits jeunes avec un homme avec
des hommes jeunes
je trouve qu'on a des relations qui sont
plus ludiques
alors ludix tout de suite les gens
croient que c'est du sexuel et qu'on
s'éclate comme des bêtes pas du tout
quand je dis ludique ça veut dire des
relations sans en enjeu où on se voit
coûte les ires de se voir où on ne sait
jamais comment ça va être la soirée et
donc il ya un petit côté d'inattendu de
légers voiles à cette insouciance des
hommes plus jeunes
je trouve que c'est une bénédiction
parce que je veux dire c'est un bain de
fraîcheur et ça n'a rien à voir avec le
physique même si cela étant c'est très
agréable de voir le bonhomme
les femmes sont de plus en plus nombreux
à avoir un compagnon ou un mari plus
jeune qu'elle elles étaient onze pour
cent il y a 20 ans 16% aujourd'hui les
femmes n'osent plus tardivement à
l'amour les plus de 50 ans qui déclarent
avoir une vie sexuelle étaient 50% il ya
20 ans elles sont 90 % aujourd'hui il
existe un phénomène de société qui
correspond au fait que souvent ces
femmes à mi vie contrairement aux
siècles passés sont extrêmement en forme
on est jeune très longtemps aujourd'hui
la femme de 50 ans ou de 45 ans de 55
ans est une femme qui est en pleine
possession de ses moyens physiques
rechercher le plaisir est devenu
aujourd'hui une affaire de femmes
et cette mère de famille est devenu une
verte et du bonheur
qui parcourt la campagne dans sa valise
musette huiles de massage une panoplie
pour réveiller le désir fort et à mesure
on facture savoir tuer tout ce qui est
objet quelqu'un alors montré quelques
exemples par exemple savoir le colibri
des objets pour apprendre à mieux se
connaître il ya beaucoup de choses
cet outil là et et est utile et il
permet d'explorer son corps est en fait
de pouvoir les déterminer son point g et
même dans les endroits les plus reculés
ses clientes sont de plus en plus
nombreuses à vouloir renouer avec une
sexualité parfois laissés de côté on se
sent presque ont pas honte ils se
feraient peut-être un petit peu exagéré
mais en ce sens c'est un petit plus
voilà j'arrive chez les gens avec mon
petit panier moi j'appelle ça mon panier
d'épicés de douceur ce jour la livraison
chez l'une de ses clientes organisatrice
de réunions de vente à domicile
une supportrice on tombe pas dans le
cliché en fait du pornographie et tu
m'as réfère le fait super bien à nous
amener ça avec la fantaisie qu'il faut
pour que cette décennie mais qu'on se
sont pas complètement à part ses dires
walsh cette perverse du village à eux
avoir envie de découvrir ses produits
pas du tout surprendre
c'est aussi l'objectif de ces femmes
lancer dans ce nouveau sport appelé la
pole dance
directement inspirée de la danse de
cabaret une façon de se sentir plus
désirable de réaliser le fantasme de la
strip teaseuse
[Musique]
ressentant peu sexy consensuel il faut
bien pour encore on est à l'aise entre
les six ont fait des choses on nous a
même pas se faire tout seul en fait à
partir du moment où elles se sentent
mieux dans leur peau qu'elle arrive à ce
après année la féminité de façon
totalement différente forcément ça va
les ouvrir au sein leur souffle ça va
ouvrir leur esprit et puis ça va leur
permettre d'avancer
quel que soit leur âge aujourd'hui les
femmes se ratera le nombre de
partenaires qu'elle déclare dans une vie
a doublé elles sont aussi de plus en
plus nombreuses à ne plus épouser leur
premier amoureux